the first season of Jackass
jackass I I wasn't even paid per episode
I was paid per bit oh we didn't get paid
at all the first season
you didn't get paid not one penny no
well we worked at the T-shirt shop so we
got 200 a week oh so that was actually a
real thing you guys actually held a job
and yeah they paid us 200 a week and
that's what we got whoa and 200 to me
for a week I'm getting every single
Friday I felt freaking rich because you
know none of us had money like that so I
was like oh my God 200 to like spend at
the bar and like go crazy so wow it was
kind of sick to us but then we were like
oh [__] like looking back now I'm like
oh my God we never got paid for the
first season so that means you're
smarter than I am
we got paid for bed it was 200 bucks if
it wasn't dangerous and it was 500 bucks
if it was dangerous oh that's [__] up
and I got I made less than 1500 bucks
after taxes for the first season
um oh my God then when when uh the show
came out when jackass came out they said
okay guys it's a hit the MTV wants to
order 16 more episodes we know we're
gonna have to pay you so we're gonna
give you 2 000 bucks per episode and
that was the point where I was oh my God
16 times 2 000 that's 32 000. I'm rich
yeah and then uh you know what nine
years later you come along and get a
hundred thousand dollars per episode
well we didn't get that to like season
three right okay and that's when we knew
like oh we're a big deal like we're
they're bringing us to La we're going on
Kimmel Fallon like all this [__] so we
were like bam right so we didn't get
that until like three when did you know
you guys were a big deal was there a
certain point I think so we filmed so we
filmed um
we filmed the first season the last
month of August and then we didn't hear
about it until like February where we're
like oh [__] because we didn't know like
how TV worked we thought it was going to
come out like the next month yeah so
like oh [__] they forgot about us like
we don't know what's happening then we
finally stole the commercial and we're
like oh my God like it's finally
happening it aired and then all of a
sudden MTV's like we gotta fly you guys
to LA and we're like um like I've never
flown to La before like I don't know I
never flew first class so they threw us
all In First Class get to La the first
stop Ashton Kutcher wants us to come
over and we're like
so we went to Ashton's and we did this
whole thing with him he helped us like
get on Twitter because that's when
Twitter just came out so right when we
knew then like going to Ashton's and
then heading to the late night shows and
doing all them we were like oh [__] like
this is like gonna change our lives yeah
it was crazy crazy ride and like the
you could see the difference because in
the first season like you guys obviously
weren't no and then
the second season all of a sudden you
guys go out to the clubs and it just the
whole place gets turned upside down yeah
so second season was Miami and you know
Miami's like crowded to begin with you
know walking down the streets like going
to all the bars and everything so it's
already crowded but seeing all the
cameras and everything and now we had
Paparazzi we felt like freaking
Kardashians I was like what is happening
we can't even walk down the street so
that's when it got so crazy that we
could hardly like film on the streets
right that and that that's when you were
in a pizzeria
Pizzeria was Italy that was Italy yeah
Miami was a gelato shop and at that
point those those jobs were like
right yeah but the first season we were
like oh my God we gotta sell these
shirts so we could get our 200
wow so it was like really hustling I I
can't remember well but was the the fact
that the job was kind of a joke like was
that clear on the show or did they like
pretend like it was a legit job like all
the jobs
um well the first season we really
really thought it was like the you know
a real job then the second season in the
gelato shop were like ah but like we
still had to go like they still would
make us get up like our bosses and be
like you got to go to work so it's not
like we could not go to work like we
still had to go we still had to and we
didn't want to be [__] because our
the boss was like so great so like we
wanted to like make a money and you know
sell the ice cream but we knew it wasn't
that serious like season one do you like
shopping on Amazon I do and good news is
Stevo's butt wipes for your butt hole
are available on Amazon and if you want
a real bundle of a deal you can get
Stevo's hot sauce for your butthole plus
Stephen's butthole destroyer and Stevo's
butt wipes for your butthole it's the
butthole bundle available on Amazon
right now
yeah dude